In this script, we want to transition
from MLP to convolutional neural
network. We explain the components of uh
CNN such as channels, paddings, strides,
poolings and um build a standard
architecture, a very small uh leanet
architecture and then we compare it with
MLP that we optimized from last time. So
these are the codes from before. I just
added a an functional um you will see
that this basically gives me some like
mathematical operation uh that I can do
fine grained control within custom NN
modules. So if you compare this uh F to
NN is like appliances with knobs and
memory and states that PyTorch has to
remember and move it around and F is
just recipes and it doesn't have a
state. Okay. So that's that. Uh we are
still in fashion amnest here. It's
important to use CUDA or GPU when
possible. Uh here for example I'm using
the the default um free T4 GPU in Google
Collab. We continue using the
normalization and the data as it
stabilizes the training. Here I noticed
last time that I was using uh the train
um for only the the train and uh test
for my validation uh which is not a good
practice because we want to leave uh the
tests part um completely unseen during
training and basically hold it out and
use the the train for both training and
validation. Uh here uh I fixed that and
I'm just using um the train for both
training and validation. So I I'm
splitting that. So the rest is pretty
much the same as before. And if you
remember, we said in MLP uh the way that
we flatten the image and destroy all the
spatial information uh makes MLP to
treat the image as a disorganized bag of
pixels which is really we making it very
hard and uh MLP has to um look at the
image as its entirety instead of looking
at different parts of the image
separately. So this makes it very
inefficient. There's no weight sharing
as we will see and it will be brutal to
translation once an object in the image
moves around the MLP will fail. So with
that let's go on and look at the
convolution uh starting with some
handcrafted kernels. So like I said we
introduce this um architecture that uh
it's based on this spatial inductive
bias that we want to induce to basically
has this properties of locality and
translation equivalence pattern is the
same regardless of where it is and the
convolution operation we showed that it
provides this bias and we we use this
analogy that the the kernel the learned
kernel or a filter is acting like a
filter Feature detection takes a
magnifying glass, a small magnifying
glass and this glass is specialized in
detecting one specific pattern. And the
detector basically slides this
magnifying glass across the image and
same weights are used everywhere. It's
the same magnifying glass which is the
concept of parameter sharing. Let's
first uh look at some handcrafted
kernels. So we want to demo this
handcrafted uh kernels. We need a data
loader uh for that and let's just choose
an image class um image index 7 probably
it's the trouser. So we want a sample
image to visualize this uh features that
the kernels are extracting. So let's
take a sample image from the data
loader. So um the data loader normalizes
the image if you remember and we have to
reverse that for visualization and
displaying um which brings the pixel
values back and uh for the range that um
is proper for visualization. Okay. So
let's uh the sample image is a tensor
right? So let's make a image numpy uh
the array version of it and it's
basically takes the sample image and we
want to uh add the mean and standard
deviation of u the data set that we
normalized and with them. Okay. So it
will be like this. So we need this image
and p for for visualization of the
image. But we have to do the convolution
over the tensor and um a tensor of a
standard size. And to do that we have to
prepare the sample image for the
convolution. And um so currently the
sample image has a shape of uh channel H
and W. Right? And the standard uh shape
for convolution must have the batch size
also. And to do that here the batch size
is one. So we just need to unsqueeze
that dimension and then send it to
device. Okay. So the image tensor will
be sample image unsqueeze and send to
device. And let's just use some kernels
that we discussed in the course. For
example, the the averaging kernel,
right? Which is a blur kernel wash
tensor.
of the same basically values on all the
3x3. Let's work with a 3x3. So it's one
over 9 multiply by 3 less. Um we can add
more kernels. For example, the the
famous edge detector kernels. And here
for example, the soal operator uh has
this form. Let's just hardcode this into
the uh into our code. So we need soal
also and so these are our kernels and
let's do a uh convolution using them and
visualize the features that they are
extracting for us. Okay. So to visualize
them let's just make a image uh we need
a row for each kernel and then can
adjust a fixed size. Let's give it a
title. Okay. So I'm doing that. I'm
going over all of these kernels and I
have to first tensorize the kernel, send
it to the device and do the convolution.
So like I said um the kernel has this uh
shape uh that is standard for the
pytorch convolution. So we have to keep
that in mind. Okay. So now with uh torch
no grad we want to do the convolution.
So the convolution will will be like
this. we are not using any uh specific
stride. So stride will be one and
padding is will be one. It means that we
just move this kernel one at a time, one
pixel at a time. And here by keeping the
padding one um the the image will stay
the same size. And um to basically let's
just call it output tensor. We want to
transform this to a numpy because I want
to visualize it. And you see that I
squeeze CPU numpy. So now we can do the
aim show and then I want to incorporate
actually let's uh first show the the
kernel which here I'm using seaborn heat
map. So this will be zero. this will be
one. Then we want to show the output
basically the features that uh is
learned and we can uh run this code and
see the result. To do that I'm just
running the the function.
Okay,
something went wrong here.
Oh yeah, I want the kernel numpy.
So the blur is basically uniform kernel.
When convolving over an input of this
shape gives us a blur shape. The
vertical extracts the vertical edges and
the horizontal extracts the horizontal
edges. So with that let's move on to
learning these kernels. Uh starting with
the components of CNN padding and
strides and then we will move on to
pooling and then the concept of
channels. So going to write a function
adding no grad will demo the pulling the
padding and stride for you.
We want to show how padding and stride
affect this the shape of an image.
Right? So assume an image of a 8 by8
shape. Let's just make it make make it
with a random normal. So like I said I
needed a standard format. So this is a
8x8 image but the first dimension and
second dimension are just the standard
that we need the batch size and channel
uh length. So we can print out the x
shape. So we want to compare it with the
conval versions and then um the default
convolution has a padding zero and
stride one. So let's imagine that KF
size three padding of zero
stride size of one and this is the the
code. It's uh let's call it convolution
doesn't have padding takes in one
channel. It outputs one channel here. In
this case, we can of course output more.
For the time being, we can output one
channel and the kernel size is three and
the default is P 0 and S1. What will be
the output? We know how to compute this,
right? I mean, we can run this of
course, but let's just talk about the
formula because we don't need to test
this out for now and we can compute it
easily. uh I mean we can test it out for
now but for a large network we want to
know how to compute this simplest case
is a one-dimensional where we have a
kernel that is sliding over this
one-dimensional what will be the length
it will be input plus twice the padding
here padding is zero but u but that's
basically the length and what's the last
index that we can take another k it's
basically this minus k we have to divide
this by the stride length And then uh
this is the last index that we can put
another one. So plus one. This is the
number of output. But maybe sometimes we
are getting a non- integer values. So we
have to take the floor of this. So here
in this case we have input of size
eight. P is 0. S is 1. K is three. So 8
+ 0 - 3 is 5 over 1. 5 + 1 6. So that
will be the output. So we expect a 6x6.
So this is that uh let's look at uh
let's play with this values of P and S.
The second case we can add padding here.
So what will be the the output? So 8 + 2
- 3 + 1 will be 8 preserves the the
shape. So let's run this. Uh let's uh
look at the another version where we can
play with the stride right so far we
kept the stride to be one. So if we do
the computation it will be so here
stride two and let's keep everything the
same. So P1 A3 okay so if we do the
computation it will be 8 + 2 - 3 / 2 and
if we take the floor of this guy it will
be four. So we are expecting a 4x4 and
let's do it. Okay. So let's try pooling.
Let's create an an imaginary image and I
want to make it deterministic because I
want to talk about this pooling
operation. So let's make a torch a range
size 4x4. So we need 16. And um so
remember we discussed two different
pooling in the lecture. one was maximum
and the other one was just averaging and
um the reason is we want the
convolutions uh to be invariant to
translation. So if we don't do the
pooling uh it is equivvariant meaning
that the feature map shifts if the input
shifts but if we only care if a feature
is present not exactly where it is uh
pooling can help here because it just
summarizes a neighborhood and it makes
the network less sensitive to the exact
location of the feature. So let's do max
pooling first which is a n max pool here
a two dimension. So let's keep size two
and let's keep this right two because
this is more intuitive. It means we look
at the 2x two parts of the image and we
we don't have any overlap. So for
example here um let's in this case of a
range uh maybe I could print this out
first. So let's do it. So here for
example if uh we look at the first 2x
two here on this part we expect five. So
let's look at the value for example of
that corner. So the output is a 2x two
and the are the output like we expect.
Uh let's add the average pooling here.
So the average pooling same kernel size
and stride and um then you see that
these are the averages. So like we
discussed max pooling detector gives out
the strongest clue and this um K2S2 is
very common. And it basically halves the
dimension. It's nonover overlapping and
we really prefer max pooling because of
this uh preservation of the strongest
feature. But average pooling is also
possible. The detector is answering this
question if u what is the general v of
this neighborhood. That's how uh we
handle uh the pooling. And then um let's
talk about the the channels which is
really the more nuanced part of this uh
convolution neural networks. So far we
discussed like one detector that uses
one kernel but we can employ several
detector that each one has a different
expertise and they use different kernel
and at the end they can report and maybe
even talk to each other to combine their
findings. Right? Let's demo that.
Same deal. I'm going to make a a
grayscale um random image, meaning that
we have one channel and since we want it
to be in a standard shape for our
PyTorch convolution, uh it should have
the batch size and the channel size and
everything. So uh let's just stochastic
rand uh we wanted to have one batch size
say batch size of one uh one channel
it's a grayscale and 28x 28 okay so now
if I do the convolution over this guy
and I instead of one detective I hire
six detective right so in that case the
in channel is one it's the raw grayscale
now channel will be six let's use
magnifying glass of size 5x5 and padding
of two for example. So that's the
convolution operation and we can apply
this on the grayscale image now. So the
y one will be kind of one over x gray
and you see the output is a batch size
of size one six channels of 28x 28 and
these are basically the the features
that this kernel basically will be
applying on. So far this is of course
unknown because we have to train this.
We can also of course um change the the
result of convolution and maybe we
should do it actually in the second if
we pass this result here that we have
which is a six uh channel 28x 28 to the
next layer of convolution. Let's say
here I have inf size six right and out
is 16. Basically we are asking each
detector to to maybe cross talk for
example if one of them finds a it's an
expert in vertical edge finds a vertical
edge in a like a neighborhood the other
one who is a expert in horizontal edge
and finds a horizontal edge in the same
neighborhood when they talk to each
other they can conclude that there is a
corner here and that's a more complex
feature. So that's why we are in a uh
more complex kind of discussion here
that now we can hire more experts uh
with more complex expertise than before.
So in this case for example we can add
padding of size two. Let's just put it
here. Let's see. And I kept this but of
course you could change this also to
reduce the size.
Let's make a a lenet at some point was
uh like a state-of-the-art really
architecture. Here we will do with some
modern flavor or batch normalization. I
want to include the number of classes to
make sure we have it for the output
layers. Let's just simplify everything.
So we need a base block. Let's just call
it block one. That is a convolution
block. uh it takes in the grayscale and
output like six channels and in line
kernel that was used here was a 5x5 and
to keep the dimension we can choose
padding of two okay so let's do it so
conf one
okay so this is uh ah I don't need this
okay so uh the architecture here that we
want to design have a first block of uh
convolution then we We'll send this to a
batch normalization and then of course
uh activation here let relu for example
and then we have to pull. So this is the
first block and then let's make another
block of this. So twice uh multiply by
two. Then after that we're done with
feature uh detection. We can flatten the
output of this. So flatten and then
three layers of uh MLP or fully
connected MLP. So that's our plan. We
want to do this. Okay. So that's the
first block that returns six channels of
the same image size. We need batch
normalization this uh so uh you will see
that uh I will have the relu
later during the forward. So I don't
need to specify it here. Okay. So we
will keep the standard kernel size and
stride and the second block takes in uh
six channels output of this guy and
returns 16 channels. Okay. So here uh
padding if padding is zero uh this will
shrink the the image. So um like I said
this six channels now interact or cross
talk meaning that in this uh layer the
kernels are really three-dimensional a
5x5 kernel and a six channel. So it's
like a three-dimensional kernel. So we
should be careful about how we are
interpreting this. So they look across
all six um input channels and
simultaneously they're looking at all
the six input channels and sum the
result. This combines the simple feature
from block one into a complex feature in
this block two. Okay. Now let's do the
max pooling. Same default. And then of
course like I said I'm just making the
blocks here. Later I will need them
together in the forward. Then we need
the MLP uh classifier head which will be
three layers. So the first layer is
basically flattening the 16x 5x5 size
images and 120 hidden neuron. Then we
pass this to the next 120 to 84 and then
the last one which is 84 to the number
of classes. So these are the logits that
we want. Let's also call the
initialization of the weight. We have to
define the function. Of course, here we
are using kiming normal. Uh we actually
we can use uh this for both linear and
nonlinear convolution. And here this is
how we initialize the the weights. And
um if bias is not initialized, we can do
that too. Here I just put zero. Okay,
let's write forward. The forward is
basically taking in uh in the first
block x and then bash norm and then
notice that I'm using relu using f and
then selfpool and then the next block
basically same thing and then we can
flatten we get a ufx that is flatten and
then we can send it to the forward
layers or the mlp head. This will return
the logic. That's it.
Okay. So uh I want to train uh both the
MLP again and uh CNN and I want to
compare them. So let's write a function
that uh basically does the job for us.
I'm still using the the same loader. So
I need a train loader and validation
loader. And I have to choose a epoch. Uh
let's just go with 10. And then learning
rate and the weight DK4 or optimizer
which year I'm planning to use Adam. So
with that uh let's do it. I want to
specify my MLP config because if you
remember we wrote it in a way that to
come up with the best architecture here.
Let's just pick up one of those
architectures that work well. We don't
need a configuration setup for the linet
CNN. It's already there as default. Um
but I'm going to make a config direct
dictionary to basically iterate over it
and train and then populate the
histories. Okay. seller configs I need
histories for both that later during the
loop I will populate them with the
history of each model and the criterion
will be cross entropy for us and then
here for each uh model let's just call
this setup the model will uh will takes
in the the name of the model and the
setup we send it to the device here is
the same optimizer for both and Then for
each model let's just uh populate the
accuracy and before training let's just
return the number of parameters of each
model. How can they fair depending on
their size? So let's report the number
of parameters. Okay. So we have MLP with
135,000 parameters and uh CNN about
62,000.
CNN uh is using this weight sharing that
we said the same kernel is reused across
the entire image uh even despite that
much less number of parameters it
performs more complex spatial op
operation as you will see. Okay, so
let's go back to the training script.
Um, so for epochs, so we want to train
one epoch, uh, the function that we
wrote from before and then evaluate and
then append it to the history. And we
can also print the progress. So we've
done this before. I'm just going to
repeat the same thing. So that's it.
This is really the uh the script. I just
need to fix this intention and that's uh
otherwise uh all good. Okay, so this is
the how we are running the training. So
in the meantime, let's just write a few
plotting scripts to investigate the
learned features and do the comparison
between the the training accuracy over
the epoch. Um and then we can also check
if the the networks are robust to uh
translation meaning that if we move an
object in an image uh we expect the
model to give us the same classification
result. Okay. So here is the result. As
uh you can see we were expecting CNN to
achieve a higher uh accuracy. But notice
that it it can do it very very early on
even though the number of uh parameters
is much less. It has a higher capacity
which is interesting and it's basically
because of the fact that the inductive
bias forces it to learn meaningful
spatial features. Okay. And here is the
next uh experiment where we are looking
at this layer weights in the first
layer. And as you can see and you've
we've seen this before, the MLP first
layer weights are really noisy global
patterns. Uh but for CNN, we have the
six structured local feature kernels
that are finding this structured and
local features. Here for example for
this uh trouser image uh we see that how
these features are um extracting what
they are uh expert in which are really
meaningful and shows clear structure
like edges gradients corners uh while
they are still local and here's a
translation test where we are shifting
the image a little bit and we see that
here the MLP correctly identify this as
shirt but with a small shift it
misidentify it. Same with other examples
too. That's that means that how brittle
is MLP. Uh we are looking at uh CNN. We
still see some uh misclassification but
it's much rare. Uh and here for example
you see that uh shifting the bag and
trouser doesn't really break the CNN.
Later we will see that uh we can do much
more with CNN. We can improve the lenet
architecture significantly with the
updates that we will talk about and also
we show that if we go for a deeper
architecture we can achieve a very good
performance. This